Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In ancient times, so it was said, the greatest of all Greek heroes had visited Italy. The story was a favourite one among the Romans. Hercules was the son of Jupiter, a paternity that had thrown Juno, the queen of the gods, into a towering rage. So irate was she at her husband's adultery that she had sent a mist of madness down upon Hercules. His insanity had driven him to commit a terrible crime, the murder of his wife and children. To expiate this, he had been sentenced by the gods to complete a series of supposedly impossible
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先看以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。相传在古代，希腊最伟大的英雄曾造访过意大利。这个故事在罗马人中非常受欢迎。赫拉克勒斯是朱庇特的儿子，这种血统让众神之后朱诺怒不可遏。她对丈夫的背叛如此愤怒，以至于她向赫拉克勒斯降下了一团疯狂的迷雾。他的疯狂驱使他犯下了可怕的罪行，杀害了他的妻子和孩子。为了赎罪，他被众神判处完成一系列据称是不可能的
labours, which, being a hero and the strongest man of all time, he had duly completed. One of these labours, the tenth, had required him to travel to a distant island beyond the setting of the sun to kill a three-headed giant and then to drive the monster's cattle all the way back to Greece. It was in the course of completing this feat that Hercules had arrived in Italy. Reaching what would one day be Rome, he had built a bridge over the Tiber and slain the local giant. Then, heading southwards, he had arrived in Campania, the rich and fertile land which stretches inland from the Bay of Naples. Here, he had found himself confronted not by one giant, but by an entire nation of them. Never a man to duck a challenge, he had fought the whole lot at once. The clash had made the earth shake, but Hercules, aided by his divine
任务，作为一个英雄和有史以来最强壮的人，他按时完成了这些任务。其中一项任务，即第十项任务，要求他前往太阳落山之外的一个遥远的岛屿，杀死一个三头巨人，然后把这个怪物的牛群一路赶回希腊。正是在完成这一壮举的过程中，赫拉克勒斯来到了意大利。到达日后成为罗马的地方后，他在台伯河上建了一座桥，并杀死了当地的巨人。然后，他向南进发，来到了坎帕尼亚，这片富饶肥沃的土地从那不勒斯湾向内陆延伸。在这里，他发现自己面对的不是一个巨人，而是一个由巨人组成的民族。他从来都不是一个逃避挑战的人，他一次与所有人进行了战斗。这场冲突让大地颤抖，但在他的神圣
father, had finally emerged triumphant from the battle. The defeated giants, their wounds still fiery from the impact of Jupiter's thunderbolts, had been chained and imprisoned by the victorious hero beneath the great mountain that rose above the Campanian plain, Vesuvius. So that, Tom Holland, is an absolutely wonderful passage from one of the great history books, isn't it? A book about Rome at the height of its empire. And that book is packed by none other than the rest is history's Tom Holland. What a moment, Tom. What a wonderful moment for you to have that so wonderfully read on the podcast.
父亲的帮助下，赫拉克勒斯最终从战斗中凯旋。战败的巨人，他们的伤口仍然因朱庇特的雷霆冲击而灼热，被胜利的英雄戴上镣铐，囚禁在坎帕尼亚平原上方高耸的伟大山峰维苏威火山之下。所以，汤姆·霍兰，这是伟大历史书中的一段绝对精彩的段落，不是吗？一本关于处于帝国鼎盛时期的罗马的书。而这本书正是由历史之余的汤姆·霍兰本人撰写的。多么美妙的时刻，汤姆。这是多么美妙的时刻，让你在播客中如此精彩地朗读这段文字。
And our subject today is, of course, that mountain. It is Vesuvius and its explosion, its eruption, and the fate of the cities of Pompeii and Herculaneum. So this is actually one of the great subjects in all history, but it's because it's one of the great sort of lessons, isn't it? It's a lesson in human hubris and our subservience to nature. It's a lesson in the sort of maxim that we're always only one step away from disaster and we're dancing on the edge of an abyss and all these kinds of cliches, don't you think?
我们今天的主题当然是那座山。它是维苏威火山及其大爆炸、火山爆发，以及庞贝和赫库兰尼姆这两座城市的命运。所以这实际上是整个历史上的伟大主题之一，但这是因为它是一种伟大的教训，不是吗？这是关于人类的傲慢以及我们对自然的顺从的教训。这是一个关于我们距离灾难只有一步之遥，我们在深渊边缘跳舞，以及所有这类陈词滥调的格言的教训，你不觉得吗？
Dancing on the edge of a volcano, Dominic. Exactly. I might almost say. Yes, it's one of the great scenes in Roman history. And it's one of two great episodes, kind of canonical episodes that take place in the reign of an emperor called Titus, who actually, he doesn't reign for very long at all. So he becomes emperor in June 79, and then he dies two years later. But not only does his reign witness the eruption of Vesuvius in 79, and we'll maybe talk about exactly when that happens, but he also inaugurates perhaps the most famous monument in the whole of ancient Rome, which is the
在火山边缘跳舞，多米尼克。没错。我几乎可以说。是的，这是罗马历史上的伟大场景之一。这是两个伟大事件之一，可以说是发生在一位名叫提图斯的皇帝统治时期的正统事件，他实际上在位的时间非常短。因此，他在公元79年6月成为皇帝，然后在两年后去世。但他的统治不仅见证了公元79年维苏威火山的爆发——我们稍后可能会讨论它具体发生的时间，他还开创了整个古代罗马最著名的纪念碑，那就是
Colosseum. So that will be the subject of the second episode in this series. But you're absolutely right, probably the destruction of Pompeii and Herculaneum is even more famous than the inauguration of the Colosseum. Of course, Pompeii is a subject we have already done in this podcast. We did it with the brilliant Hay, who was, I think, her first guest, wasn't she? Her first ever guest in the rest of history. She came on to talk about the archaeology of Pompeii, all the latest discoveries, all that sort of thing. But this is more about the story and about Vesuvius and the role that Vesuvius plays in it. About the destruction, the process of destruction. Exactly. It's a story that we can kind of piece together, drawing on various sources. So we've got the written sources. So we have two
斗兽场。这将是本系列第二集的主题。但你完全说得对，庞贝和赫库兰尼姆的毁灭可能比斗兽场的落成还要出名。当然，庞贝是我们在这个播客中已经做过的主题。我们邀请了才华横溢的海伊，我想她是第一个嘉宾，不是吗？她在《历史的其余部分》中的第一位嘉宾。她来谈论庞贝的考古学，所有最新的发现，诸如此类的事情。但这个故事更多的是关于故事，关于维苏威火山以及维苏威火山在其中扮演的角色。关于毁灭，毁灭的过程。没错。这是一个我们可以通过各种来源拼凑出来的故事。所以我们有书面资料。所以我们有两封
very, very famous letters written by Pliny the Younger, who was a young man at the time, about 18. And he was asked by the great Roman historian Tacitus to give his account. He was an eyewitness of it. And so he does this in two letters. And the reason that Pliny the Younger was an eyewitness is that he was present with his uncle, Pliny the Elder, the great encyclopedist, I think very much a friend of the rest of his history, who was also, when he wasn't writing his encyclopedia, the admiral of the great fleet at Mycenae, which is just down the Bay of Naples from Herculaneum. So we have those written sources.
非常非常著名的信件，由小普林尼撰写，他当时是个年轻人，大约18岁。大罗马历史学家塔西陀要求他提供自己的说法。他是目击者。所以他在两封信中做到了这一点。小普林尼之所以是目击者，是因为他和他的叔叔老普林尼在一起，老普林尼是一位伟大的百科全书编纂者，我认为他是历史其余部分非常好的朋友，当他不写百科全书时，他也是美森大舰队的舰队司令，该舰队位于赫库兰尼姆附近的那不勒斯湾。所以我们有这些书面资料。
Then, of course, we have the archaeology, which Sophie talked about in the episode she did with us. The archaeology enables us to trace what happened with the eruption right the way down to what happens to people who try to escape. We have the remains of over 1,500 people who've been discovered there. You can tell from objects that they're carrying, path that they're taking, what their last desperate moments were. It's incredibly vivid, incredibly moving. Also, intriguingly, archaeology helps us to date when in the year the eruption happened. According to Pliny the Younger, or at least the transcript of the letters that we have,
然后，当然，我们有苏菲在与我们合作的那集节目中谈到的考古学。考古学使我们能够追溯火山爆发时发生的事情，一直追溯到试图逃跑的人身上。我们在那里发现了1,500多具遗骸。你可以从他们携带的物品、他们走的路线看出他们最后绝望的时刻是什么样的。这真是太生动了，太感人了。同样有趣的是，考古学帮助我们确定火山爆发发生在一年中的什么时候。根据小普林尼的说法，或者至少根据我们拥有的书信记录，
he dates it to the 24th of August. But the question that has been raised, actually, I mean, for many centuries, I mean, going right the way back, I think to the 18th century, this began to be proposed, that actually the remains of crops and of food materials that have been found in the cities point to a date in autumn. And so that this, I think, is probably now the consensus that the date of the 24th of August is a mistranscription. It's not just recently as people have found pomegranates, wine, which seems to date it to autumn. Many of the people who've been found seem to have been wearing quite heavy clothes, so clothes unsuited to the dog days of summer. And a charcoal inscription was found in 2018, which is dated to the 17th
他将其定在8月24日。但实际上已经提出了一个问题，我的意思是，几个世纪以来，我的意思是，一直追溯到，我想是18世纪，人们开始提出这一观点，即在城市中发现的农作物和食物材料的残骸实际上指向了秋天的日期。因此，我认为，现在这可能已经成为共识，即8月24日的日期是错误转录。这不仅仅是最近人们发现石榴、葡萄酒，这似乎可以追溯到秋天。许多被发现的人似乎穿着相当厚重的衣服，所以衣服不适合盛夏的炎热日子。2018年发现了一个木炭铭文，其日期为17日
of October. So it's unlikely that that would have stayed there for an entire year. So it suggests that probably the eruption happened after the 17th of October. Right. Yeah. So all of that is evidence. And then on top of that, Dominic, there's science in the form of volcanology. Okay. How can that possibly date the eruption? It doesn't. It enables us probably to, if volcanologists drawing on Pliny's descriptions of what happens, are able to work out what happens when a volcano like Vesuvius erupts and map it onto the archaeology, kind of cross-reference with the literary sources, and basically enable us to work out the chain of events that happened those two terrible days, the day of the eruption. So just before we get into the story, just to give people a sense of the geography, we're in Southern Italy, the Bay of Naples. Vesuvius is southeast of Naples, dominating the
十月。所以它不可能在那里呆上一整年。这表明火山爆发可能发生在10月17日之后。对。是的。所以所有这些都是证据。然后除此之外，多米尼克，还有火山学形式的科学。好的。这怎么可能确定火山爆发的日期呢？它没有。它使我们可能，如果火山学家利用普林尼对发生的事情的描述，能够弄清楚像维苏威火山这样的火山爆发时会发生什么，并将其映射到考古学上，与文学来源进行某种交叉引用，并基本上使我们能够弄清楚那两个可怕的日子里发生的事件链，火山爆发的那天。所以在我们进入故事之前，为了让人们对地理有一个概念，我们在意大利南部，那不勒斯湾。维苏威火山位于那不勒斯东南部，俯瞰着
bay. And Pompeii and Herculaneum are these two towns that are sort of nestled under Vesuvius, aren't they, between Vesuvius and the sea. Yeah. And important to point out that although Pompeii and Herculaneum are the two most famous cities affected by the eruption, the Bay of Naples has a lot of highly, highly significant cities. So Naples most obviously, but it also has Puteoli, which is the great port. This is where the grain ships coming from Africa and Egypt to feed Rome come. So this is crucial to the entire functioning of the Roman economy. We have Mycenae, which I already mentioned, which is the headquarters of the fleet. There are various other towns dotted along the coast. And these are very, very
海湾。庞贝和赫库兰尼姆是这两座坐落在维苏威火山下的小镇，不是吗，在维苏威火山和大海之间。是的，需要指出的是，尽管庞贝和赫库兰尼姆是受火山爆发影响最著名的两座城市，但那不勒斯湾有许多非常非常重要的城市。所以最明显的是那不勒斯，但它也有普特奥利，这是一个伟大的港口。这是来自非洲和埃及的运粮船到达罗马的地方。因此，这对罗马经济的整个运作至关重要。我们有我之前提到过的迈锡尼，这是舰队的总部。沿海点缀着各种其他城镇。这些是非常非常
high-end resorts, villas. So this is Monte Carlo. This is the most attractive, stylish, most fashionable sea resorts that you could have anywhere in the world at the time. But it is also a center of industry because, as the Romans understood, there is a peculiar quality to the ash that is in the neighborhood. It can be mixed with water to create concrete that sets onto water. And it's this that enables both the pleasure piers that stick out from resorts like Baiae or from the individual villas that are owned by the super rich, but it's also what enables them to build the great kind of groins and moles that stick out into the sea that enable the harbours to be built.
高端的度假村、别墅。所以这里是蒙特卡洛。这是你在当时世界上任何地方都能拥有的最具吸引力、最时尚、最时髦的海滨度假胜地。但它也是一个工业中心，因为正如罗马人所理解的那样，邻近地区的火山灰具有一种奇特的品质。它可以与水混合制造在水面上凝固的混凝土。正因为如此，无论是从拜伊等度假村或超级富豪拥有的私人别墅延伸出来的娱乐码头，还是使港口得以建造的延伸到海中的巨大防波堤和突堤，都得以建造。
So although the Romans don't know that Vesuvius is a volcano, they do understand that geologically it's very unusual. And this is where the stories of giants being buried underneath Vesuvius come from. So this sense that Pliny the Elder, for instance, doesn't think that it's buried giants. He kind of is aware that there are geological explanations that don't depend on that. But it is definitely part of the appeal of the area, I think, the sense that it has a supernatural quality to it. Right. And do people have a sense that does the earth ever shake? Is the smoke coming out of the mountain or these kinds of things? The earth shakes and the earth has been shaking quite badly
因此，尽管罗马人并不知道维苏威火山是一座火山，但他们确实明白从地质学上讲它非常不寻常。这就是埋藏在维苏威火山下的巨人的故事的来源。所以这种感觉，例如老普林尼，并不认为那是被埋葬的巨人。他有点意识到有一些不依赖于此的地质解释。但这绝对是该地区吸引力的一部分，我认为，它具有超自然品质的感觉。对。人们是否有这种感觉，大地曾经摇晃过吗？山里有烟冒出来还是诸如此类的事情？大地在摇晃，大地一直在剧烈摇晃
in the decades before the final eruption. So we can date a very, very violent earthquake that hits Pompeii on the 5th of February, 62, and also Herculaneum. So Seneca, the advisorth of February, 62, and also Herculaneum. So Seneca, the advisor and teacher to Nero, he reports that part of Herculaneum had collapsed and that the buildings that are left standing, he wrote, are very unsteady. It's also reported back in Rome that large stretches of Pompeii have been leveled. This is probably an exaggeration, but the damage does seem to have been pretty severe. So in Pompeii, the Temple of Jupiter,
在最终火山爆发前的几十年里。因此我们可以追溯到公元62年2月5日袭击庞贝的非常非常剧烈的地震，以及赫库兰尼姆。所以尼禄的顾问兼老师塞涅卡，二月，62，还有赫库兰尼姆。因此，尼禄的顾问和老师塞涅卡报告说，赫库兰尼姆的一部分已经倒塌，他写道，仍然耸立的建筑物非常不稳定。罗马也有报道称，庞贝的大片地区已被夷为平地。这可能是一种夸张，但破坏似乎相当严重。所以在庞贝，朱庇特神庙，
which stands on the forum, this had been brought kind of crashing down. Various bath complexes have been put permanently out of action. Plaster has fallen off. There's enormous amounts of work for builders and renovators to do. And for the 17 years that have followed this earthquake in 62, basically Pompeii and Herculaneum have been absolute highs of activity. The hammering has never stopped. If you were sailing into Pompeii, so it has a kind of harbor, the largest temple in the town is to Venus, the goddess of love, who is the patron of Pompeii. This remains an absolute building site. We can tell this because of the archaeology. The sediment that buries Pompeii enables archaeologists to see the trenches that have been dug, the building material that lies
耸立在广场上，这座神庙轰然倒塌。各种浴场永久性地停止了运转。灰泥已经脱落。建筑工人和装修工有大量的工作要做。在62年地震之后的17年里，庞贝和赫库兰尼姆基本上一直是绝对高度活跃的地方。锤击声从未停止。如果你航行进入庞贝，它有一个类似港口的地方，镇上最大的神庙是献给爱神维纳斯的，她是庞贝的保护神。这里仍然是一个绝对的建筑工地。我们可以通过考古学看出这一点。埋葬庞贝的沉积物使考古学家能够看到被挖出的战壕，堆积的建筑材料
piled up, the sense in which this temple has only been half built. Now, of course, the fact that they're renovating it is a statement of faith in the future of the city. It's saying, we don't think that these earthquakes are so fatal that we should get out, even though it's possible that certain people have left, that people have read the runes. But Pompeii is definitely a functioning city in the summer of 79 and probably moving into the autumn. And Pompeii and Herculaneum, you mentioned there were those resorts. Well, Pompeii less so. Herculaneum is much more of it. It's kind of much more upmarket. Pompeii is is a working town it's a working town yeah right pompeii is bigger than herculaneum is i assume it's actually hard to tell because most of pompeii is buried under the modern town so it
堆积起来，这座神庙只建了一半的感觉。现在，当然，他们正在对其进行翻新，这是对这座城市未来的信心声明。这是在说，我们不认为这些地震是如此致命，以至于我们应该离开，尽管某些人可能已经离开，人们可能已经读过符文。但在公元79年的夏天，庞贝绝对是一座正常运转的城市，并且可能正在进入秋天。庞贝和赫库兰尼姆，你提到过那些度假村。好吧，庞贝没那么多。赫库兰尼姆更像是这样。它更高档一些。庞贝是一座工人阶级小镇，它是一座工人阶级小镇，是的，庞贝比赫库兰尼姆大，我猜这其实很难说，因为庞贝的大部分都被埋在现代小镇下面，所以它
hasn't been fully excavated okay um i guess it's kind of much of a muchness should we get fast forward to the key so in the year 79 yeah titus is the emperor. He has followed his father Vespasian, who's the general who's taken power at the end of the year of the four emperors at the end of this period. And there are signs, aren't there, in the summer, I suppose, or maybe slightly later in the autumn, that something is happening. Is it earth tremors? Is it smoke? Yeah. So there are tremors are coming back again. I mean, Pliny reports this, and it is noted with considerable alarm by people in Pompeii that springs on the slopes above the city are drying up. This is what Robert Harris in his brilliant novel Pompeii does. It's a novel set against the backdrop of a hydronaut engineer trying to work out why the springs have stopped and gradually arriving at the terrible truth. And even as engineers are trying to work out what is happening to the water supply, people in the neighborhood of Pompeii and Herculaneum are reporting that they are seeing strange figures striding over the landscape, such creatures in fact as the
没有被完全发掘，好吧，嗯，我猜这差不多是一回事，我们应该快进到关键时刻，对吧？所以在公元79年，是的，提图斯是皇帝。他继承了他的父亲韦斯帕西安，后者是在四帝之年结束时掌权的将军。迹象表明，对吧，在夏天，我想，或者可能稍后在秋天，有什么事情正在发生。是地震震颤吗？是烟吗？是的。所以震颤又回来了。我的意思是，普林尼报道了这一点，庞贝的人民对此感到相当惊慌，他们注意到城市上方斜坡上的泉水正在干涸。这就是罗伯特·哈里斯在他精彩的小说《庞贝》中所做的。这是一部以水文学家试图弄清楚泉水为什么停止流动并逐渐得出可怕真相为背景的小说。正当工程师们试图弄清楚供水系统发生了什么时，庞贝和赫库兰尼姆附近的人们报告说，他们看到奇怪的身影在风景中大步走过，实际上就是
giants are supposed to have been. So very, very ominous. And yet, as I say, despite these very worrying portents, life carries on. And we can tell this from the archaeology. So we know that donkeys are milling bread, that wine is being made, that's being gathered, that people are conducting their business. And then suddenly, everything changes. Everything changes utterly. And as far as Pompeii and Herculaneum are concerned, forever. And the amazing thing here, Tom, is that we have an account of that moment, don't we? So this is what is so astonishing about it, that we know that the eruption happens about an hour after midday. We don't know the precise date, but we know the exact time. And we know this because at Mycenae,
巨人应该有的生物。所以非常非常不祥。然而，正如我所说，尽管有这些非常令人担忧的预兆，生活仍在继续。我们可以从考古学中看出这一点。所以我们知道驴子在磨面，葡萄酒正在酿造，正在采集，人们在进行他们的生意。然后突然间，一切都变了。一切都彻底变了。就庞贝和赫库兰尼姆而言，永远改变了。神奇的是，汤姆，我们有关于那个时刻的记录，对吧？所以这就是令人震惊的地方，我们知道火山爆发发生在中午过后大约一个小时。我们不知道具体日期，但我们知道确切的时间。我们知道这一点是因为在迈锡尼，
where Pliny the Elder and his nephew are settled, Pliny the Elder's sister comes in and says to her brother, who's lying on a couch reading a book, that a remarkable cloud has appeared in the sky. And so Pliny the Elder, who is always fascinated by natural phenomena, kind of rushes out and he looks out over the Bay of Naples and he sees that his sister had not been exaggerating. It's a cloud like nothing anyone has seen. In appearance and shape, it most closely resembled a pine tree, Pliny the Younger later writes. For it had a column of great length and height as though it were a trunk overtopped by a number of branches. But I guess we today, if we saw it, probably describe it as a mushroom cloud. Terrifying. Yeah. Such a chilling image. Completely terrifying. And Pliny is fascinated by this. He thinks, oh, I must go and investigate it.
老普林尼和他的侄子住在那里，老普林尼的姐姐进来对躺在长椅上看书的哥哥说，天空中出现了一朵不寻常的云。于是，老普林尼对自然现象总是很着迷，他急忙冲出去，眺望那不勒斯湾，他看到姐姐并没有夸大其词。这是一朵前所未见的云。小普林尼后来写道，在外观和形状上，它最像一棵松树。因为它有一根很长很高的柱子，就像一根树干，顶部有许多树枝。但我想我们今天如果看到它，可能会把它描述为蘑菇云。太可怕了。是的。多么令人不寒栗的形象。完全令人恐慌。普林尼对此很着迷。他想，哦，我必须去调查一下。
And so he orders a galley to go over and see what's happening. And the thing is that what's interesting is that he can't yet tell where this cloud is coming from. So we can see it's rising from a mountain, but he can't tell that it's coming from Vesuvius. But in Pompeii and Herculaneum, they can absolutely tell what's going on. So Herculaneum is at the base of Vesuvius and they are right underneath this massive spreading cloud. Well, to them, I guess it's both a cloud, but more vividly, it's a column. It's a column of ash and rock. And minutes after the eruption, it is miles up in the sky and it blocks out the sun. So although it's just after midday, suddenly they're being pitched into darkness. And then after about 30 minutes, a kind of a drizzle of pumice and ash begins to fall. And in Herculaneum, it's very, very light because the breeze is coming from Naples and it's blowing
于是他命令一艘三列桨战船过去看看发生了什么。有趣的是，他还不知道这朵云是从哪里来的。所以我们可以看到它从一座山上升起，但他看不出它是来自维苏威火山。但在庞贝和赫库兰尼姆，他们绝对能看出发生了什么。所以赫库兰尼姆位于维苏威火山的山脚下，他们就在这片巨大的扩散的云层正下方。好吧，对他们来说，我更认为这既是一朵云，但更生动的是，它是一根柱子。这是一根由火山灰和岩石组成的柱子。火山爆发几分钟后，它就在几英里高的天空中，遮蔽了太阳。因此，尽管刚过中午，他们突然陷入了黑暗。然后大约30分钟后，一种毛毛雨般的浮石和火山灰开始落下。在赫库兰尼姆，这是非常非常轻的，因为微风来自那不勒斯，它在吹拂
the pumice and the ash away from Herculaneum towards Pompeii, which is kind of further down. And so people in Herculaneum are thinking, ooh, this is not good news. And so large numbers of them start piling up wagons or carrying bags of their possessions and streaming away from the cloud of drizzle of pumice towards Naples. Meanwhile, in Pompeii, there it is absolutely kind of pitch black because the downpour of pumice is much, much thicker. And so the darkness there is pretty much total. The only light is kind of along the line of the horizon to south and east, so in the opposite direction from Vesuvius. But it's kind of, you know, it's like a very, very faint and feeble dawn.
浮石和火山灰从赫库兰尼姆向庞贝飘去，庞贝在更下游。所以赫库兰尼姆的人们心想，哦，这不是好消息。因此，他们中的很多人开始堆叠马车或携带装有他们财产的袋子，从浮石毛毛雨的云层中流向那不勒斯。与此同时，在庞贝，那里绝对是一片漆黑，因为浮石倾盆而下要厚得多，厚得多。所以那里的黑暗几乎是完全的。唯一的亮光是沿着南部和东部的地平线，也就是与维苏威火山相反的方向。但这有点像，你知道的，就像一个非常非常微弱和微弱的黎明。
And so people are literally coming out with torches. Is that right, Tom? And lamps and stuff. It is basically like night. So otherwise they can't see a thing. And as they are coming out with their torches, so they're having to start wading through the streets because the pumice is starting to pile up and block their exit.
所以人们真的拿着火把出来，是这样吗，汤姆？还有灯什么的。基本上就像夜晚一样。否则他们什么也看不见。当他们拿着火把出来时，他们必须开始涉水穿过街道，因为浮石开始堆积并堵塞了他们的出口。
And so people in Pompeii obviously are also trying to escape, but it's much, much harder for them than it is for people from Herculaneum because their path is blocked. I mean, in your description in Pax, you say, you describe how people are looking at their streets or their own homes and they observe how the roofs are straining under the weight of the load and increasingly as the hours passed giving way. And actually, to me, the interesting words there are as the hours passed. So people are paralyzed, a lot of people, I suppose. It's a temporary phenomenon, but they're not all hiding out of the city in one go, are they? People are presumably reacting in very different ways. I mean, I think you need help to remove your
因此，庞贝的人民显然也试图逃跑，但对他们来说，这比赫库兰尼姆的人要困难得多，因为他们的去路被挡住了。我的意思是，你在《帕克斯》中的描述中，你描述了人们如何看着他们的街道或他们自己的房屋，他们观察到屋顶在负载的重量下如何拉紧，并且随着时间的推移越来越多地让步。实际上，对我来说，那里有趣的话语是随着时间的流逝。所以人们瘫痪了，很多人，我想。这是一个暂时的现象，但他们并不是一下子都躲出城外的，对吧？人们大概有非常不同的反应。我的意思是，我认为你需要帮助来搬走你的
belongings. So if you have wagons or if you have slaves, then maybe it's easier. But even that is dangerous because firstly, the roads are being blocked. So if you're taking your wagon out and all this pumice is piling up and then it gets stuck, what are you going to do? You can't shelter anywhere. So I think lots of people think, well, we'll stay in our houses and hope that it will blow over. But also the other thing is that fragments of rock have been blasted up with the force of column of ash that has gone up. These lumps of rock are also starting to drop. You don't know when they're going to come, but at any minute you might be smacked on the head by a lump of rock. So that is also increasing the jeopardy. And so I think that, I mean, it's such an invidious choice. Do you take to the road and risk being stranded there by the pumice or hit on the head by a fragment of rock? Or do you kind
物品。所以如果你有马车或者如果你有奴隶，那么也许会更容易。但即便如此也是危险的，首先，道路被堵塞了。所以如果你开着马车出去，所有的浮石都堆积起来然后卡住了，你要怎么办？你无处避难。所以我认为很多人想，好吧，我们会呆在家里，希望它能过去。但另一件事是，岩石碎片被随着灰烬柱的力量向上喷射。这些岩石块也开始掉落。你不知道它们什么时候会来，但随时你都可能被一块岩石砸到头上。所以这也增加了危险性。所以我认为，我的意思是，这是一个多么痛苦的选择。你是上路并冒着被浮石困在那里或被岩石碎片砸到头部的风险？还是你
of hide in your cellar and hope that it will go away? But then of course, there's the risk that, as you say, the pumice might just kind of build up such a kind of weight on the roof and it all collapses and then you're trapped there. So I mean, horrible, horrible decision. The other alternative, of course, is to try and escape from the harbour. And so lots of people think, well, we'll take that option, rush down to the harbour. But there also also the pumice is forming a kind of very thick scum on the face of the sea. And so ships can't pull out. And this is a problem also for ships trying to come in. And the main squad of ships that are trying to come in are led by Pliny.
藏在你的地窖里，希望它会消失？但随之而来的风险是，正如你所说，浮石可能会在屋顶上积聚如此之重的重量，然后全部倒塌，然后你被困在那里。所以我的意思是，可怕的，可怕的选择。当然，另一个选择是尝试从港口逃生。所以很多人认为，好吧，我们会选择那个选项，冲向港口。但那里浮石也在海面上形成了一层非常厚的浮渣。所以船只无法开出。这对试图进港的船只来说也是一个问题。试图进港的主力船队由普林尼率领。
Because Pliny, in the intervening time, has been alerted to the fact that actually it's not enough for him to go and do a scientific investigation. He needs to conduct a full-scale evacuation. And he's been tipped off about this by a letter that has been sent to him by a woman who has a villa in the vicinity of Pompeii saying, things are really kicking off here. And what's interesting about that is that that letter must have been sent before the actual eruption. So it suggests that the tremors are so violent that this villa owner is thinking, we've got to get out of here. And that would have reached him by boat. Should have sent a boatman with the letter.
因为普林尼在此期间接到警报，实际上他去进行科学调查是不够的。他需要进行全面疏散。他从一个住在庞贝附近的女人寄给他的信中得到了这个消息，信中说，这里真的要爆发了。有趣的是，那信一定是在实际爆发之前寄出的。所以这表明震动非常剧烈，以至于这位别墅业主认为，我们必须离开这里。那会乘船到达他那里。应该派一个船夫带着信。
Yeah, probably. So that's arrived. And so Pliny has set off at the head of an entire fleet to try and affect this evacuation. But he pulls up into the harbour at Pompeii and he discovers that he just can't get in. And so he's thinking, well, what am I going to do? Should I turn back? That's not very Roman. And it's very much not Pliny. Pliny wouldn't want to turn back and avoid the chance to investigate this fascinating phenomenon. And also the winds are against him. So he decides that he will head on along the bay, so away from Pompeii, southwards towards a place called Stabiae, which again is a kind of very chic resort. And he has a friend there, a senator by the name of Pomponianus, who has a villa. So Pliny thinks,
是的，可能。所以信已经到了。于是普林尼率领整支舰队出发，试图实现这次撤离。但他驶入庞贝港，发现自己根本进不去。所以他在想，好吧，我要怎么办？我应该回去吗？这不太像罗马人。这很不符合普林尼的风格。普林尼不会想回去并避开调查这个迷人现象的机会。而且风对他也极为不利。所以他决定继续沿着海湾前进，远离庞贝，向南朝一个名为斯塔比亚的地方前进，这也是一个非常时尚的度假胜地。他在那里有一个朋友，一个名叫庞培安努斯的参议员，他有一栋别墅。所以普林尼想，
I'll go and see how he's getting on and maybe kind of take a rain check there, a pumice check. They arrive in Stabiae and they find that Pomponianus is down in the bay, desperately trying to get away. And they're facing the same problem. The pumice is too thick now. And so effectively by heading for Stabiae, Pliny has ensured that he's now stranded there. Pliny is still being very measured about it. He's trying to play the cool, hard-headed, practical man of action, keep everyone's panic at bay. So he takes Pomponianus in in his arms, kind of tries to reassure him, suggests that they go back up to the villa and they arrive there. And Pliny is very kind of, you know, I mean, filthy, streaked with ash. And he says, well, I think I'll have a bath. That is extraordinary behavior, Tom, in these circumstances.
我去看看他过得怎么样，也许在那儿检查一下雨水，检查一下浮石。他们到达斯塔比亚，发现庞培安努斯在海湾里，拼命地想要逃离。他们面对着同样的问题。浮石现在太厚了。所以实际上，通过前往斯塔比亚，普林尼确保了他现在被困在那里。普林尼对此仍然非常克制。他试图扮演冷静、头脑清醒、实际的行动派，让所有人的恐慌平息。所以他把庞培安努斯抱在怀里，试图安慰他，建议他们回到别墅，他们到达了那里。普林尼非常，你知道的，我的意思是，满身污垢，布满火山灰。他说，好吧，我想我去洗个澡。汤姆，在这些情况下，这是非同寻常的行为。
It's very cool. A volcano is erupting around you and you're like, well, I think I'll take a bath just because I'm a bit... It's very carry on up the Khyber. It's kind of stiff up a lip. Very stiff up a lip. Very stiff upper lip. Very stiff upper lip. So he goes up and he has his bath and then he comes out and he says,
这太酷了。火山在你周围爆发，你就像，嗯，我想我去洗个澡，只是因为我有点……这很像《凯伯河上的继续》。这是一种硬着头皮的做法。非常硬着头皮。非常坚忍。非常坚忍。所以他上去洗了个澡，然后出来说，
you know, well, what's for dinner? Such an impressive display of sang froid. I mean, we have to bear in mind that this account is being written by his nephew who loved him very much. But I still think, I mean, it's clearly, these are reports from people who survived the eruption, who saw his behavior and were evidently very, very impressed by it. So Pliny says, Pliny the Younger says of his uncle that at dinner, he was in perfect spirits,
你知道，晚餐吃什么？表现出如此令人印象深刻的镇定自若。我的意思是，我们必须记住，这份叙述是由非常爱他的侄子写的。但我仍然认为，我的意思是，很明显，这些都是从在火山爆发中幸存下来的人那里得到的报告，他们看到了他的行为，并且显然留下了非常非常深刻的印象。所以普林尼说，小普林尼谈到他的叔叔时说，在晚餐时，他情绪高涨，
or at least with a show of good spirits that was under the circumstances, no less remarkable than the genuine thing. And this is even as the skies are black, the waters are filling up with the scum of pumice, the ash is raining down and there's rumbling and the earth's shaking and they're of pumice and this sense of a kind of universal darkness. I mean, terrifying enough, but worse is to come. And I think we should take a break at this point. And then when we come back, we'll talk about how death is preparing to claim Herculaneum and we will see how death claims Herculaneum. Oh, what a terrifying story. So we'll see you after the break.
或者至少表现出一种在当时情况下同样不同寻常的良好精神状态。即使天空变黑，海水中充满了浮石的浮渣，火山灰下雨般落下，伴随着隆隆声和大地颤抖，还有浮石的感觉和一种普遍的黑暗感。我的意思是，这已经够可怕的了，但更可怕的还在后面。我想我们此时应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将讨论死神如何准备夺走赫库兰尼姆，我们将看到死神如何夺走赫库兰尼姆。哦，多么可怕的故事。我们休息后再见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开了娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Polini the Elder, having just had his bath, is having dinner. He's having his lovely, elegant dinner under a blackened sky as ash is filling the air and pumice is raining down. Now, Tom, you ended the first half by saying that death was about to engulf Herculaneum. So talk us through what happens next. Okay. So this is noted by Pliny and his fellow guests at Stabiae, kind of a few miles on from
欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。老普林尼刚洗完澡，正在吃晚饭。他在漆黑的天空下享用着可爱而优雅的晚餐，火山灰填满了空气，浮石如雨般落下。汤姆，你在前半部分结束时说死神即将吞噬赫库兰尼姆。给我们讲讲接下来发生了什么。好的。普林尼和他在斯塔比亚的同伴们注意到了这一点，这里距离
Vesuvius, and that they are looking back towards where Vesuvius looms. I mean, they can't see it because everything is pitch black, but they suddenly start seeing fire. And this is about three or four hours before midnight. And if you're in Herculaneum, you are right underneath this vast jet of red flames starting to rise from the summit of the mountain. And it can be seen through all the kind of the billowing black clouds and lightning starts to flare through the ash and great jagged bolts of fire. And people cry out, the giants are coming. They have woken, they're coming, they are breaking free of their chains and there's absolute pandemonium and terror, but still the worst is to come. So this is by now it's midnight has come and gone. And then
维苏威火山，他们回过头去望向维苏威火山耸立的地方。我的意思是，他们看不到，因为周围一片漆黑，但他们突然开始看到火光。这大约是午夜前三四个小时。如果你在赫库兰尼姆，你就正好在这个巨大的红色火焰喷射流下方，它开始从山顶升起。透过所有翻滚的黑云都可以看到它，闪电开始在火山灰中闪烁，巨大的参差不齐的火光。人们大声尖叫，巨人来了。他们醒了，他们来了，他们正在挣脱锁链，绝对是一片混乱和恐慌，但最糟糕的还在后头。此时午夜已过。然后
abruptly about 12 hours after the initial eruption, spectators in Herculaneum, they're watching the lightning shimmer. They're watching it kind of stab and fork above them. And then suddenly, apocalypse descends on them. And it descends on them in the form of a great glowing red cloud, what volcanologists call a pyroclastic surge. And it has emerged from the column of ash. It's begun to flow down the side of Vesuvius and it is advancing at an unspeakable speed. And people watching it, I mean, of course they cry out in terror. They try to run from it,
在初次火山爆发大约12小时后，赫库兰尼姆的观众们正在观看闪闪发光的闪电。他们看着它在他们上方刺穿和分叉。然后突然间，末日降临到他们身上。它以一大团发光的红云的形式降临到他们身上，火山学家称之为火山碎屑涌流。它从火山灰柱中涌出。它开始顺着维苏威火山的山坡流下，并以无法形容的速度前进。看着它的人们，当然，他们惊恐地尖叫。他们试图逃跑，
but it's impossible because it is moving so fast that it simply can't be outrun. Your description, Tom, which I just read your description, which is so powerful. All perished equally. The avalanche of ash and pumice and gas moving at ferocious speed overwhelmed the entire city in a matter of minutes. No living creature could survive the terrible heat. Skin was vaporized. Intestines were boiled. Brains bursting through skulls dissolved on the passage of the fiery cloud. Heads were knocked off statues. Beams, tiles, walls, all were sent flying. The entire city was left buried. The entombment of Herculaneum had begun. Scorching scene. It's reminiscent of the footage that you always get in films about nuclear war, when the bomb lands and suddenly you're seeing glass and everything just shattering
但这是不可能的，因为它移动得太快了，根本无法跑过它。你的描述，汤姆，我刚读了你的描述，是如此有力。所有人无一幸免。火山灰、浮石和气体以惊人的速度移动的雪崩在几分钟内席卷了整座城市。任何生灵都无法在可怕的高温下生存。皮肤被气化了。内脏被煮沸了。大脑冲破头骨，在炽热云层的通道中融化。雕像的头部被撞掉。梁、瓦、墙，全都被吹飞了。整座城市都被埋葬了。赫库兰尼姆的掩埋已经开始。焦黑的场景。这让人想起你在关于核战争的电影中总是看到的镜头，当炸弹落地时，突然间你看到玻璃和一切都在碎裂
everywhere. I mean, that's what it's like. So no one can survive this. A firestorm. It's like a firestorm. It's like the bombings of Germany or Tokyo in World War II. And it doesn't matter where you are. So it doesn't matter whether you are on the harbour trying to get away. It doesn't matter whether you are hiding in the cellars, which is where the elderly women with children have gone. They all die equally. And basically, Herculaneum, by this point, is already buried beneath ash and rubble and all the kind of accumulated rock that has descended in this pyroclastic surge. And it is evident to people right the way along the length of the Bay of Naples that something absolutely terrible has happened.
到处都是。我的意思是，这就是它的样子。所以没有人能幸免。火风暴。这就像一场火风暴。这就像二战中德国或东京的轰炸。你在哪里并不重要。所以你在港口试图逃跑并不重要。你躲在地窖里也并不重要，带着孩子的年老妇女就是这么做的。她们都同样死去。基本上，到这个时候，赫库兰尼姆已经埋在了火山灰、瓦砾以及在这场火山碎屑涌流中降下的所有累积岩石下面。对于那不勒斯湾沿岸的人们来说，很明显发生了一件非常可怕的事情。
They can't see it because, of course, the darkness remains very, very thick, blotting out the moon and the stars. But the change in the behavior of the mountain and the progress of the eruption can be felt by people in the air. So Pliny in Stabiae, he has been trying to downplay the significance of the lightning display that's been kind of forking above Vesuvius and has, again, with tremendous sangfa, has insisted on retiring to bed. But there are very few people at Stabiae who follow his example, which is just as well because people are still awake that they can see that the pumice
他们看不到，因为当然，黑暗仍然非常非常浓重，遮蔽了月亮和星星。但山脉行为的变化和火山爆发的进程可以通过空气中的人们感受到。所以在斯塔比亚的普林尼，他一直试图淡化在维苏威火山上方分叉的闪电表演的重要性，并且再次以极大的镇定自若，坚持退房睡觉。但斯塔比亚很少有人效仿他的榜样，这很好，因为人们仍然醒着，他们可以看到浮石
is falling so heavily that Pliny is starting to be trapped in his bedroom. And so they force their way through the pumice, knock down the door, get Pliny out. And even Pliny has to acknowledge, yeah, this isn't looking good. And so they face the same dilemma that had confronted people in Herculaneum. Do you hide in the cellar or do you go down to the sea? And so they decide that they will go down to the sea, get down to the ship, see if perhaps there's a chance of getting away. They start heading down towards the sea, get down to the ship, see if perhaps there's a chance of getting away. They start heading down towards the shore. They take pillows to put over their head because by this point, chunks of rock are falling in ever greater pace, ever greater speed, ever greater
下得如此猛烈，以至于普林尼开始被困在卧室里。于是他们强行穿过浮石，撞开门，把普林尼救了出来。甚至连普林尼也不得不承认，是的，这看起来不太好。因此，他们面临着与赫库兰尼姆人相同的困境。你是躲在地窖里还是去海边？于是他们决定去海边，走到船上，看看是否有机会逃跑。他们开始向海岸走去。他们拿着枕头盖在头上，因为此时，大块的岩石以越来越快的速度、越来越快的速度、越来越大的
volume. They light torches. They pick their way down to the docks, but the winds are still contrary. The pumice is too thick in the harbor. There is no prospect of making their escape on ship. So a slave spreads out a sheet and Pliny, who is by now wheezing very, very heavily, he seems to have been asthmatic, lies down on it, calls for a cup of water, calls for a second cup of water, waits for the wind to turn, but the wind is continuing to blow in his face and the ash and pumice is continuing to fall and the horror is inescapable. And you were saying about him wheezing, I mean, he's not a young man, he's 55. And there must have been people dropping dead with fright, I mean, or struggling to breathe or all these
体积掉落。他们点燃火把。他们摸索着走到码头，但风仍然逆风。港口里的浮石太厚了。乘船逃生的希望渺茫。于是，一个奴隶铺开了一张床单，此时喘息得非常厉害、似乎有哮喘的普林尼躺在上面，要了一杯水，又要了第二杯水，等待风向转变，但风继续吹向他的脸，火山灰和浮石继续落下，恐惧是不可逃避的。你刚才说他气喘吁吁，我的意思是，他不是年轻人，他55岁了。一定有人吓得倒地身亡，我的意思是，或者呼吸困难，或者所有这些
kinds of things. So at this point, it's an apocalyptic scene, isn't it? I mean, it's like something from a nightmare. Right. So, I mean, obviously Herculaneum by this point has gone. Everyone in Herculaneum is dead. Pompeii is still standing, but there you're absolutely still in the eye of the storm. But the horror of it is now spreading right the way along the Bay of Naples. So just as it is terrifying for Pliny and his companions in Stabiae, so also is his nephew, Pliny the Younger, who's been left behind in Mycenaeum. It's terrifying for them as well. There are tremors, there's the lightning crashing, there's this pyroclastic surge that they've been able to see, the one that buried
事情。所以此时此刻，这是一个末日般的场景，不是吗？我的意思是，这就像噩梦中的情景。所以，我的意思是，很明显赫库兰尼姆到这个时候已经消失了。赫库兰尼姆的所有人都死了。庞贝仍然屹立不倒，但你在那里绝对仍然处在风暴中心。但它的恐怖现在正沿着那不勒斯湾蔓延。正如普林尼和他在斯塔比亚的同伴们感到恐惧一样，留在迈锡尼的小普林尼也是如此。这对他们来说也很可怕。有震颤，有闪电轰鸣，有他们能看到的这场火山碎屑涌流，埋葬了
Herculaneum. So of course, people are thinking that it's the end of the world. They have no idea what is happening, just that the doom of mankind seems to have arrived. So the same convulsions that in Stabii have persuaded Pliny and his companions to go down to the shore and wait there. In Mycenaeum, on the other side of the Bay of Naples, have jolted Pliny the Younger and his mother awake. And so they come out of their rooms and they go out into the courtyard and they kind of, like everybody else, wonder, well, what should we do? So Pliny the Younger, absolutely a chip off the old block, he decides the obvious thing
赫库兰尼姆。所以当然，人们觉得世界末日到了。他们根本不知道发生了什么，只觉得人类的末日似乎已经降临。因此，在斯塔比亚，那些说服老普林尼和他的同伴们走到海岸边并在那里等待的同样的动荡，在那不勒斯湾的另一边的米塞纳姆，也把小普林尼和他的母亲惊醒了。于是他们从房间里出来，走到庭院里，和所有人一样，心里纳闷：嗯，我们该怎么办？于是小普林尼，真是有其父必有其子，他决定最明显的做法
to do at this point is to get out a book and sit in the courtyard and read it, which I think, again, is a tremendous tribute to his commitment to scholarship and his love of reading. So that's what he does. And they wait for dawn and then dawn comes. And it is evident as dawn comes that actually sitting around and reading a book isn't probably the best policy. So even the younger Pliny is forced to accept that. And so he orders carts to be loaded. So all the choice belongings from the villa. And then he and his mother and their escorts and their slaves start pushing the wagons out of Mycenaeum, anything to get away, basically.
在这个时候要做的事情是拿出一本书，坐在院子里读，我觉得这再次证明了他对学术的执着和对阅读的热爱。这就是他所做的。他们等待着黎明，然后黎明降临了。随着黎明到来，显然坐在那里读一本书可能并不是最好的策略。因此，连年轻的普林尼也不得不接受这一点。于是他命令装载马车。把别墅里所有的精选物品都搬上车。然后他和他的母亲、随从以及奴隶们开始把大车推出米塞纳姆，基本上只要能逃跑，什么都行。
And as they do so, everyone else is doing the same. The whole naval base is emptying. And they reach open ground, try to stabilize their carts, which are kind of rolling and rocking everywhere. It's very kind of difficult to do that. As Pliny is doing that, trying to make sure that the wagons aren't kind of rolling back down the hill, he keeps looking over his shoulder. And by now, there is sufficient light. It's very, very faint. It's very watery, but he can look out to sea and he can see an absolutely astonishing scene. Namely, that where the sea had been, there is now nothing but dry land. And so you can imagine all the fish and the other marine creatures, they've been left stranded.
当他们这样做时，其他人也在做同样的事情。整个海军基地都在清空。他们到达开阔地带，试图稳住他们的马车，马车在各处颠簸摇晃。这很难做到。正当普林尼这样做时，试图确保马车不会顺着山坡滑回去，他不断回头张望。到这个时候，已经有足够的光线了。非常非常微弱。光线像水一样苍白，但他可以望向大海，看到一幕绝对令人震惊的景象。也就是说，原本是大海的地方，现在只剩下干涸的土地。你可以想象所有的鱼和其他海洋生物都被搁浅了
They're kind of twitching and gasping in the open air, littering the sands. And in the distance, the mushroom cloud can now be made out absolutely terrifying in fact also dominic what it's like is maybe it's kind of quite lord of the rings because that mushroom cloud kind of is crowned by fire yeah you could imagine it so the explosion of mount doom or indeed what happens to numenor tom yes in the sumerium Anyway, we're getting into fantasy. So what's happened in, well, let's start with Herculaneum. What's happened in Herculaneum? Completely buried? Yeah, completely buried and being buried in ever more pyroclastic flows. Because what's happening by this point is that the column of ash and rock that had risen up above Vesuvius,
它们在露天中抽搐和喘息，散落在沙滩上。而在远处，蘑菇云现在已经清晰可见，绝对令人毛骨悚然。事实上，多米尼克，这感觉就像什么呢？也许有点像《指环王》，因为那团蘑菇云上面像是戴着火冠。是的，你可以想象出来，末日火山的爆发，或者诺门诺尔发生的遭遇，汤姆，是的，在《精灵宝钻》里。总之，我们开始陷入幻想了。那么，发生了什么，好吧，让我们从赫库兰尼姆开始。赫库兰尼姆发生了什么？完全被埋葬了吗？是的，完全被埋葬，并且被越来越多的火山碎屑流所掩埋。因为这时候发生的事情是，维苏威火山上空升起的灰烬和岩石柱，
it had reached miles and miles and miles into the sky, it is now starting to collapse. And so it's that that periodic levels is sending these kind of great clouds of fire-edged dust crashing down the side of the mountain and rolling over Herculaneum. So I reckon that by dawn, the hours after dawn, the time when Pliny the Younger is looking at the dry sea, by that time, nothing at all remains of Herculaneum. It's been buried beneath maybe 100 feet of rubble. And so the entire shoreline has been transformed by this. So if it's possible for people to look towards Herculaneum, it's not only that there'd be no trace of the town, there would also be no trace of the familiar shoreline. It would be utterly transformed. Terrifying.
它已经冲入了数英里高的高空，现在开始坍塌。因此，正是这种周期性的崩塌，将这些滚烫的、边缘带火的巨大尘埃云向下冲击着山坡，滚滚卷过赫库兰尼姆。所以我估计在黎明时分，黎明之后的几个小时里，当小普林尼看着干涸的大海时，在那时，赫库兰尼姆已经荡然无存了。它被埋在大约100英尺深的瓦砾下了。整个海岸线都被这改变了。所以如果人们有可能望向赫库兰尼姆，不仅会找不到这个镇子的痕迹，连熟悉的海岸线也无迹可寻。它将被彻底改变。太可怕了。
This sense that the giants have awoken and they are not just destroying cities, but reshaping the very contours of the earth. I mean, completely terrifying. However, in Pompeii meanwhile, no pyroclastic surge there. With the coming of dawn, there's the sense that the rain of pumice is starting to subside. And so for the first time since the eruption, they're able to start seeing the streets around them. Now, what they see is not entirely reassuring because basically it's not just the streets have piled high with the pumice, but all the buildings are absolutely buried beneath it.
这种感觉就像巨人们已经醒来，他们不仅在摧毁城市，还在重塑大地的轮廓。我的意思是，极其可怕。然而，与此同时在庞贝，那里没有火山碎屑涌浪。随着黎明到来，浮石雨开始消退。因此，自火山爆发以来，他们第一次能够看清周围的街道。现在，他们看到的并不是完全让人安心，因为基本上不仅街道上堆满了浮石，而且所有的建筑都完全被埋在浮石之下了。
And a lot of these buildings have collapsed. The roofs have collapsed. So from across the city, there is the sound of the screaming of people who are buried beneath it, begging for help. But it's impossible. You can't. Seemed that the very city, like a crippled beast, was moaning in pain. You have people sobbing and crying. You have dogs howling in agony and fear and hunger. I mean, a complete, I scene. But those who have not been buried beneath the pumice, those who can escape their hiding places, it does seem now that there is an opportunity for them to make their escape. And so they start stepping out into this very, very watery ghostly light,
许多建筑已经倒塌。屋顶塌了。因此，从全城各处，都能听到被埋在下面的人们的尖叫声，他们在呼救。但这是不可能的。你做不到。感觉这座城市就像一头残疾的野兽，在痛苦中呻吟。你可以听到人们在啜泣和哭泣。你可以听到狗在痛苦、恐惧和饥饿中狂吠。我的意思是，一个完整的，地狱般的场景。但是那些没有被浮石掩埋的人，那些能够逃离藏身之处的人，现在看来他们确实有机会逃跑了。于是他们开始踏入这微弱的、幽灵般的微光中，
picking their way over the rubble, over the pumice, and doing it, of course, as urgently as they can. You get different groups of people heading for different gates. We know this because their remains have been preserved. You can trace how there were men leading their families, slaves lugging heavy sacks, children holding hands as they run, all of them heading towards the various gates that lead out of the town. We know that there was a doctor who was carrying his box of medical instruments. We know that there was a temple servant who had bundled up all the most precious treasures of the shrine. So the statues of the gods, struggling not to drop them as he runs. And there's a group
在瓦砾和浮石上艰难前行，当然，尽可能紧急地这样做。你会看到不同的人群朝着不同的城门走去。我们知道这一点，因为他们的遗骸被保存了下来。你可以看到男人们带着家人，奴隶们拖着沉重的麻袋，孩子们手拉着手奔跑，所有人都朝着通往镇外的各个城门走去。我们知道有一位医生带着他的医疗器械箱。我们知道有一个神庙仆人打包了圣地最珍贵的宝物。神像们在他奔跑时挣扎着不让它们掉落。还有一群
of about 20 fugitives, one of whom is a woman who is hugging to herself this tiny statue of Fortuna, the goddess of good luck. Heartbreaking details, Tom. Yeah, you would do. Dominic, is Fortuna, is she smiling on these people as they try to escape? No, I know because I've been to Pompeii, so I've seen the figures. So lots of people have seen those figures. They're not the original figures, are they? They're plaster casts, are they, of the space? So all you have is the space.
大约20名逃难者，其中有一个女人正紧紧抱著小小的福尔图娜雕像，那是好运女神。让人心碎的细节，汤姆。是的，你会这么做的。多米尼克，福尔图娜女神在这些试图逃跑的人脸上露出微笑吗？不，我知道，因为我去过庞贝，所以我看过那些雕像。所以很多人都看过那些雕像。它们不是原来的雕像，对吧？它们是那些空洞的石膏模型，对吗？所以你拥有的只是那个空间。
Yes, exactly. Because it is at this point, as people are trying to make their escape, that the final collapse of the Great Column of Ash finally happens. And this surge does bury Pompeii. And it is the largest, the most monstrous of all the pyroclastic flows. And it absolutely buries Pompeii. As with Herculaneum, so now it is simply too fast to be escaped. And so it kills every living creature in its path. And we know how people try to cope with it. So there are people who raise pieces of cloth to their mouths, no help at all. There are slaves who are shackled and the heat fuses the fetters to the bones of the slave. Famously, there's a dog. I mean, I'm sure everyone will have seen
是的，完全正确。因为正是在这个时候，当人们试图逃跑时，巨大的火山灰柱最终迎来了最后的坍塌。这次涌流确实掩埋了庞贝。这是所有火山碎屑流中最大、最庞大的一次。它彻底埋葬了庞贝。就像赫库兰尼姆一样，现在它蔓延得太快，根本无法逃脱。因此，它杀死了路径上的每一个生灵。我们知道人们是如何试图应对它的。所以有人把碎布举到嘴边，一点用也没有。有被镣铐锁住的奴隶，高温将镣铐熔化进奴隶的骨头里。最有名的就是那只狗。我的意思是，我相信每个人都会看到
the mold of the dog who again had been kind of tethered by the entrance of his master's house and kind of writhing in its death throes. And the ash falls, the rubble falls, everything is buried. So there's a line from Marshall, isn't there? All lay sunk in flames and dismal ash, a fate that the gods themselves might have wished had not been in their power. So Marshall is a great poet. Famous for his epigrams and actually also famous for writing about the inauguration of the Colosseum. I mean, it is actually quite moving to see, isn't it?
那只狗的铸模，它同样被栓在他主人的屋子入口处，在垂死挣扎中扭曲着。火山灰落下，瓦砾落下，一切都被埋葬了。马提尔有一句名义上的诗，不是吗？一切都在烈火和惨淡的灰烬中沉没，连神明自己或许都希望这种命运不属于他们的力量。所以马提尔是一位伟大的诗人。以他的讽刺短诗闻名，实际上也因描写斗兽场的落成典礼而闻名。我的意思是，亲眼见证这一切确实挺感人的，不是吗？
Even at such a vast distance in time, almost 2000 years, to see the figures frozen at the moment of their deaths, the dog, as you say, the woman with the cloth, the slaves and so on, the people holding hands, all of that kind of thing. I mean, it's an absolutely terrifying lesson in mortality and in our own vulnerability. And I think even more so because we have, in the form of the letter written by Pliny the Younger to Tacitus, an account of what it was like to experience that final collapse of the Great Column of Ash and survive it. Right. Because he's at a distance. Yeah. So he is on the high ground above Mycenae. They've got their wagons,
即使在如此漫长的时间跨度之后，将近2000年，看到那些在死亡瞬间定格的身影，正如你所说的狗、拿着布的女人、奴隶等等，人们手拉着手，所有这些场景。我的意思是，这是关于人类终有一死和自身脆弱性的极其可怕的一课。而且我认为更是如此，因为我们通过小普林尼写给塔西陀的信，获得了关于经历那场巨大火山灰柱最终坍塌并幸存下来的真实记录。没错。因为他身处远处。是的。所以他在米塞纳姆上方的高地上，他们带着马车，
they've tried to escape the town, and they're looking back and they see the great avalanche of rubble and fire that buries Herculaneum for the last time and destroys Pompeii. And it continues to kind of ripple out. It's pulsing across the Bay of Naples. It's burying Naples. It's burying Puteoli. It's burying by obliterating them completely and heading towards Mycenae. And people start to kind of scream on it coming. And Pliny describes it as dense blackness that swept ever onwards, spilling over the earth in a great flood. And then it hits them. Again, Pliny says it's like the dark of a deep prison that had never known light.
他们试图逃离小镇，他们回头看着滚滚的瓦砾和火焰雪崩，最后一次埋葬了赫库兰尼姆并摧毁了庞贝。它继续向外扩散。它在那不勒斯湾波涛汹涌地推进。它正在埋葬那不勒斯。它正在埋葬普特奥利。它通过完全抹去它们来埋葬一切，并向米塞纳姆进发。人们开始在它到来时尖叫。普林尼将之描述为席卷一切的浓黑，如同一场巨大的洪水漫过大地。然后它击中了他们。普林尼再次说道，这就像是一个从未见过光明的黑暗深牢。
And he describes how children sob, how parents are screaming for their lost sons and daughters, how people are weeping, some for themselves, Pliny says, and some for the world itself, which they think is finishing. For if there were many who raised their hands to the gods, then there were many others who declared the gods to be no more, and that the darkness would last forever, and that the world was at its end. And they see through the dark spits of fire, flickerings of fire, and then the fire is gone, and then it's all blackness again. The ash continues to fall. Pliny says how he and his mother think that they're going to suffocate. They're holding their hands to their mouths, desperately trying to get breath into their lungs
他描述了孩子们如何啜泣，父母如何为失去的儿女尖叫，人们如何哭泣，普林尼说，有些人为自己哭泣，有些人为世界本身哭泣，他们认为世界正在走向终结。因为如果说有许多人向神明举起双手，那么也有许多人宣称神明已不复存在，黑暗将永远持续，世界已经走到了尽头。他们透过黑暗看到点点火光，火焰的闪烁，然后火熄灭了，接着又是一片漆黑。火山灰继续下落。普林尼说他和他的母亲以为他们会窒息。他们把手捂在嘴上，拼命想让空气吸入肺里
without suffocating themselves. And they genuinely think that this is the end of the world, that they're doomed. And then the darkness starts to become visible smoke. And the sun, of course, blood red, but it starts to shine very dully through the veil of thick black cloud. And as the ash, the darkness starts to dissipate, Pliny the Younger is looking around and he can see that Mycenaeum is still standing. And then it lifts again and they can see by the great seaside resort, that's still standing. And Potioli, the great harbor is standing and Naples is standing. But when they look towards where Herculaneum had stood and where Pompeii had stood,
而不会让自己窒息。他们真心觉得这就是世界末日，他们死定了。然后黑暗开始变成可见的烟雾。太阳当然是血红色的，但它开始透过厚厚的黑云幕布极其黯淡地照耀着。随着火山灰和黑暗开始消散，小普林尼环顾四周，他可以看到米塞纳姆依然完好无损。接着云雾再次散去，他们可以看到那个伟大的海滨度假胜地依然屹立。普特奥利这座伟大的港口依然挺立，那不勒斯也依然挺立。但是当他们望向曾经是赫库兰尼姆和庞贝的地方时，
nothing in the landscape has changed completely. So they are gone. Meanwhile, on the far side of the bay, the same cloud that has swept over Mycenaeum has reached Stabii. Pliny the Elder, he's very asthmatic. He's very elderly. He's exhausted. He's been sitting there there they don't see the the cloud coming but then they get this kind of stench um a stench of uh sulfur and it gets stronger and stronger and at this point everyone in plinny's party rise to their feet and panic they start running away from it but plinny can't he's too shattered he's too old two slaves stay with him however they try and help him to his feet plinny takes a step forward he totters collapses. The smell of sulfur worsens. The cloud of ash grows thicker. The darkness becomes total and the slaves flee and no one knows what has become of Pliny the Elder. And then two days
风景中没有任何东西保持原样——它们全都不见了。与此同时，在海湾的另一侧，席卷了米塞纳姆的那片云朵已经抵达了斯塔比亚。老普林尼，他患有严重的哮喘。他年纪很大了。他精疲力竭。他一直坐在那里，他们没有看到云朵飘来，但接着他们闻到了一种恶臭，一股硫磺的恶臭，而且越来越浓。此时，普林尼随行的所有人都惊慌失措地站起身来，开始逃离，但老普林尼跑不动，他太虚弱了，太老了。有两个奴隶留下来陪他，他们试图扶他站起来，老普林尼向前迈出一步，摇晃了一下，倒下了。硫磺味更浓了。火山灰云更厚了。黑暗变得彻底，奴隶们逃跑了，没有人知道老普林尼遭遇了什么。然后两天
later, a search party arrives on the scene where Pliny the Elder had last been seen and they discover him. He hasn't been gnawed at by scavenging animals. He hasn't been brained by a lump of rock or anything. He looks as though he's lying there asleep. Golly, what a terrifying story. So Pompeii is gone. Herculaneum has gone. Presumably, our sources are sketchy.
后，一支搜救队到达了老普林尼最后被发现的地点，找到了他。他没有被食腐动物啃咬。他没有被一块岩石砸碎脑袋或其他什么。他看起来就像是躺在那里睡着了。天哪，多么可怕的故事啊。所以庞贝消失了。赫库兰尼姆消失了。据推测，我们的资料很简略。
People must have been digging there for days, hoping to find loved ones. Well, and looting. It seems, again, from the archaeological evidence, that people in the immediate aftermath of the eruption do kind of start going down, either to try and recover their belongings or to loot it or whatever. There are lots of refugees. They spill over the Bay of Naples. Some of them go all the way up to Rome and to Ostia, the port outside Rome. I mean, the reverberations spill right away across the Mediterranean. So the ash is causing kind of spectacular atmospheric displays as far afield as Syria. Crikey. And we know this from the sources of the time. It's interpreted in apocalyptic terms, unsurprisingly, by Judean sources. So Titus, the emperor in whose reign this happens, is the general who had captured Jerusalem. And so there are kind of apocalyptic writings by Judeans that say this is the judgment of God.
人们一定在那里挖掘了好几天，希望能找到亲人。嗯，还有掠夺。从考古证据来看，火山爆发后不久，人们确实开始往下走，要么是为了找回自己的财物，要么是为了掠夺，诸如此类。有很多难民。他们涌入那不勒斯湾。其中一些人一路逃到了罗马以及罗马港口奥斯蒂亚。我的意思是，余波一直扩散到整个地中海。因此，火山灰在远至叙利亚的地方引起了壮观的大气景象。天哪。我们从当时的文献中得知这一点。不出所料，犹太文献将其解释为世界末日的迹象。因此，提图斯——在这场灾难发生期间在位的皇帝——就是攻陷耶路撒冷的将军。因此，有一些犹太人的末日经文说这是上帝的审判。
And there is definitely a feeling in Rome as well, that this can only be the manifestation of divine anger. And as we'll see when we do our episode on the Colosseum, I think that this plays quite an important role in the way that the opening of the Colosseum is framed by Titus. I was going to ask about that because we haven't done many natural disasters on the rest of its history, but one we did do is the Lisbon earthquake in the mid-18th century, which had a profound impact on the mentality of the Enlightenment in shaking people's faith. Famously, Voltaire wrote about it in Candide, shaking people's faith. Famously, Voltaire wrote about it in Candide, shaking people's faith in a benevolent God and in a divine plan and all
罗马也有一种明确的感觉，即这只能是神明愤怒的显现。正如我们稍后在做关于斗兽场的单集时会看到的，我认为这在提图斯构建斗兽场开幕式的方式中扮演了相当重要的角色。我本想问这个，因为我们在它的其他历史中没有做过很多自然灾害，但我们做过的一个是18世纪中叶的里斯本大地震，它对启蒙运动的心态产生了深远的影响，动摇了人们的信仰。伏尔泰在《老实人》中对此进行了著名的描写，动摇了人们的信仰。伏尔泰在《老实人》中对此进行了著名的描写，动摇了人们对仁慈上帝和神圣计划的信仰，以及所有
these kinds of things. Do you think that the eruption of Vesuvius in 79, do you think that had a similar effect on the Romans? Or did people just sort of say, well, stuff happens? I think it has a really profound effect. I think it's buried in the sources. When you think that the Romans don't believe that the gods are benevolent in the way that Christians believe that the Christian God is benevolent. The Roman gods are, you worship the gods, you pay your dues to the implication is that you haven't taken out enough insurance. The rule both of Titus and of his younger brother Domitian, who succeeds him and is commemorated in the sources as a brutal tyrant. I think a lot of what certainly both Titus and definitely Domitian do are reflections of their attempt to appease the gods. The feeling that everything that is happening in Rome is because the gods are offended, they haven't been given their dues, and therefore a lot of what Titus, and particularly Domitian, does is an attempt to get the gods back on side. Okay. Just on Pompeii itself, while people are propitiating the gods, is Pompeii just abandoned?
这些事情。你认为公元79年维苏威火山的爆发对罗马人产生了类似的影响吗？还是人们只是觉得，嗯，事情就是会发生？我认为它产生了非常深远的影响。我认为这隐藏在历史文献中。当你想到罗马人并不像基督徒相信基督教上帝那样相信神明是仁慈的时。罗马的神明是，你崇拜神明，你尽了你的本分，言下之意是你没有买足够的保险。提图斯和他的弟弟图密善（继位并在史料中被记为残酷暴君）的统治。我认为提图斯和图密善所做的大部分事情，肯定反映了他们试图安抚神明的努力。这种感觉是，罗马发生的一切都是因为神明被冒犯了，他们没有得到应有的祭祀，因此提图斯尤其是图密善所做的大量事情都是为了重新赢得神明的支持。好吧。就在庞贝本身，当人们在向神明赎罪时，庞贝就被废弃了吗？
Yeah, it's abandoned. Yeah. And pretty much forgotten. And then excavations begin in the 18th century and have been ongoing and are still not completed. And on Vesuvius itself, the propitiation of the gods actually didn't work because Vesuvius is still one of the world's most dangerous volcanoes. I mean, I'm just reading here. There have been eruptions 203, 472, 512, 1660, 1682, 1694, and so on and so on and so forth, killed more than 100 people in 1906, 1944, US planes, which were based there, destroyed. And even now, just reading there, the Italian government has a contingency plan to evacuate 600,000 people. Yeah. I mean, isn't this an extraordinary thing that even though we know what happened to
是的，它被废弃了。是的。而且几乎被遗忘了。然后发掘工作在18世纪开始，并一直在进行，至今仍未完成。而在维苏威火山本身，向神明赎罪实际上并没有起作用，因为维苏威火山仍然是世界上最危险的火山之一。我的意思是，我正在这里阅读资料。在203年、472年、512年、1660年、1682年、1694年等等发生过火山爆发，1906年和1944年造成100多人死亡，驻扎在那里的美国飞机被毁。甚至现在，我刚刚在这里读到，意大利政府制定了一项疏散60万人的应急计划。是的。我的意思是，这难道不是很不寻常吗？尽管我们知道发生了什么
Pompeii and Herculaneum, there are still 3 million people living in the Bay of Naples? Well, because the volcanic soil is incredibly rich. It's what provides the concrete that enables the Bay of Naples to be the kind of architectural cutting edge. It's the Bay of Naples where, for instance, domes are developed, which will then feed into the Pantheon in Rome, the Dome of Hagia Sophia, the domes that are characteristic of Islamic architecture. It all ultimately originates from the excellence of the concrete that is provided there. And also there's this region called the Phlegarian Fields, which is
庞贝和赫库兰尼姆，那不勒斯湾仍然生活着300万人？嗯，因为火山土壤非常肥沃。正是它提供了混凝土，使那不勒斯湾成为建筑前沿。正是在那不勒斯湾，例如发展出了圆形穹顶，这些穹顶后来被引入罗马的万神殿、圣索菲亚大教堂的穹顶，以及伊斯兰建筑特征的穹顶。这一切最终都源于那里出产的优质混凝土。这里还有一个叫做“坎皮费格瑞”的地区，它是
kind of marked by fire and ash and things, but are also spectacularly fertile so that they can have two harvests. So the risk of being wiped out by a volcano is the tax that people have paid on the fertility and the productivity of the environments around Vesuvius. Death is the tax we pay for life, Tom. But so your passages on this in your book, Pax, I mean, they're brilliantly done. It's an incredibly sort of sobering read. Just writing that, you know, that must have been a highly charged chapter to write, I would guess. Yeah. And it was piecing together all the various elements of the evidence, as I said, the literary, the archaeological, and the volcanological, to work out what actually happened when it happens, what it would have been like to witness it and to experience it.
被火、灰烬等标志着，但也极其肥沃，以至于可以一年收割两次。因此，被火山消灭的风险是人们为维苏威火山周围环境的肥沃和生产力所支付的税收。死亡是我们为生命支付的税收，汤姆。但是，你在书《Pax》中关于这部分的篇章，写得太精彩了。这是一部极其清醒的读物。仅仅是写下这些，你知道的，我猜写那一章一定充满了强烈的感情色彩。是的。正如我所说，这是将各种证据拼凑在一起，文学、考古和火山学的证据，以弄清楚当它发生时究竟发生了什么，亲眼目睹并经历它是怎样的感受。
It was a thrilling piece of writing to do. All right. Well, a thrilling piece of writing. The book is Pax, War and Peace in Rome's Golden Age. Tom, we've never plugged it before and the rest is history, obviously. I haven't mentioned it. Never mentioned. This will come as a complete shock to many of your admirers to know that you've been writing this book and that it's now on sale. If I do have a besetting fault, it's modesty.
这是一段激动人心的写作经历。好的。嗯，一段激动人心的写作经历。这本书是《Pax：罗马黄金时代的战争与和平》。汤姆，我们以前从没有宣传过它，历史就是这样，显然。我没有提过。从没提过。对于你的许多崇拜者来说，这会是一个巨大的震惊，得知你一直在写这本书，而且现在已经上市了。如果我有什么根深蒂固的缺点，那就是谦虚。
What a note on which to end. It's an extraordinary and harrowing story. So thank you very much, Tom. And on that note, thank you very much and goodbye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host
多么完美的结束语。这是一个非凡且令人痛心的故事。非常感谢你，汤姆。就此而言，非常感谢，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持
The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
《娱乐真相》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一撮演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前获得现场门票的权限，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那就是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。